[Musique]
Alors que l'Arctique continue de se réchauffer
et que la banquise fond, nous voyons plus d'ours
sur le rivage et plus d'endroits
et pendant de plus longues périodes
[Musique]
en même temps, le nouvel océan ouvert
permet  plus de gens à venir dans l'
Arctique
et donc nous mettons en place ce
scénario parfait pour une interaction accrue entre les ours humains
et un conflit accru entre les ours humains
[Musique]
nous essayons de devancer cela en
développant de nouvelles technologies et de nouveaux outils
et aussi pour nous assurer  les personnes qui vivent,
travaillent et jouent dans l'Arctique disposent d'
outils de dissuasion pour se protéger
et protéger les rochers
[Musique]
ce projet consiste à déterminer si ce
système radar conçu à des fins militaires et
de sécurité
peut détecter les ours polaires susceptibles
d'entrer dans les communautés ou  camps,
en particulier en période de faible visibilité la
nuit pendant les tempêtes de neige, etc.
parce que le radar peut voir à travers tous
[Musique]
que
donc des années 1980 jusqu'à environ 2011, nous avons vu
plus de 20 déclins dans cette sous-population,
puis nous avons eu environ un  décennie où il
semblait que les choses s'étaient stabilisées, elles
ne se sont pas améliorées
mais elles ne se sont pas aggravées, ce déclin
a repris depuis
et donc les dernières données non publiées
suggèrent maintenant une
baisse de 30 dans cette sous-population et continue
[Musique]
si  nous n'agissons pas assez rapidement pour
maîtriser les émissions en réduisant
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre, il est très
clair
que l'ouest de la baie d'hudson, en tant que l'une des
populations d'ours polaires les plus au sud
du monde,
va probablement disparaître dans les années à venir
[Musique]
vous